ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen es
wird mal wieder spät im Kanzleramt der
Bundeskanzler der Finanzminister und der
Wirtschaftsminister Arbeiten erneut
daran Lösungen im Haushaltsstreit zu
finden seit dem frühen Abend sitzen sie
wieder zusammen wenn sie sich noch in
der Nacht einigen dann könnte der
Haushalt morgen im Kabinett beschlossen
werden wenn nicht dann wird's wohl
nichts mehr in diesem
Jahr 17 Milliarden Euro fehlen sagt der
Bundesfinanzminister wo werden die jetzt
eingespart und was ist eigentlich mit
der Schuldenbremse darüber spreche ich
gleich mit der Wirtschaftsweisen
Professor Veronika Grimm aber erstmal
sprechen wir darüber wie wahrscheinlich
denn eine Einigung ist wenn ihr dazu
Fragen habt schickt sie uns an
zfheute-live@zdf.de per Mail oder wie im
mal schreibt sie in die Kommentare
daniel ponzen ist unser
hauptstadtkorrespondent in Berlin jetzt
hoffentlich gleich zu sehen hier genau
vor dem weihnachtlichen Brandenburger
Tor es ist schon wieder dunkel in
Berlin Daniel wie wahrscheinlich ist es
denn dass es heute eine Einigung gibt
und ist schon irgendwas nach draußen
gedrungen es ist noch nicht nach außen
gedrungen außer dass es heute
wahrscheinlich keine Einigung geben wird
ich denke das ist tatsächlich sehr
unwahrscheinlich dass es eine solche
Einigung geben könnte aus zwei Gründen
zum einen sind es halt wirklich sehr
sehr dicke Bretter die da geboht werden
müssen das ist halt wirklich inhaltlich
sehr sehr viel zu einen und es gibt ja
diesen bekannten Spruch hier in Berlin
es ist nichts geeint bis nicht alles im
Detail vereinbart ist insofern wird mich
das wundern wenn man da heute
tatsächlich schon zu einem Ergebnis käme
vor allem aber auch vor dem Hintergrund
des zweiten Grundes nämlich äh es gab ja
jetzt eben dieses Urteil vom
Bundesverfassungsgerichts und gestern
dann noch mal vom
Bundesrechnungshof ähm den Hinweis oder
man könnte auch sagen den Rüffel dass
das was man jetzt mit Blick auf das Jahr
2023 vorgelegt hat nämlich den
Nachtragshaushalt
äh dass da auch einiges wieder
problematisch sei und das letzte was man
in der Bundesregierung will
das jetzt dass man jetzt wieder ein
Haushalt auch fürs nächste Jahr vorlegt
der dann möglicherweise wieder
anfechtbar ist vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht und das war
auch mal die Losung die der Kanzler
ausgegeben hat sehr sehr schnell soll
man sich einigen aber eben auch so
gründlich wie nötig und das ist glaube
ich in dem Fall keine Floskel sondern
tatsächlich die marschrute dass man hier
auch mit der gebotenen Gründlichkeit
vorgehen will insofern wird mich das
sehr überraschen wenn es heute da noch
weißen Rauch bildlich gesprochen aus dem
kanzlerand gäbe nun interessiert die
User natürlich an vielen Stellen wo denn
jetzt gespart werden könnte aber
natürlich interessiert vor allem auch
der politischer Aspekt und deshalb die
Frage an dich äh von einem User auf
Youtube der fragt wie wahrscheinlich ist
es ist dass Lindner ein zweites Mal sagt
es ist besser nicht zu regieren als
falsch zu regieren
ich halte das für sehr unwahrscheinlich
aus dem einfachen Grund
dass wenn die Ampel jetzt platzen würde
im Grunde keine keiner der ampelpartner
davon profitieren würde die FDP
wahrscheinlich am allerwenigsten die
steht im Moment in manchen Umfragen bei
unter 5% das heißt wenn es jetzt eine
Neuwahl gäbe in absehbarer Zeit würde
die FDP Gefahr laufen wieder aus dem
Bundestag rauszufliegen en wir schon mal
in der jüngeren Vergangenheit ähnliches
gilt auch für die SPD die ja in manchen
Umfragen zuletzt in vierter
Stelle ins Ziel kam sozusagen hinter
drei anderen Parteien auch die dürften
kein Interesse derzeit an Neuwahlen
haben die Grünen sind noch am stabilsten
was ihre Umfragewerte angeht
aber ich würde nicht davon ausgehen dass
es da in Kürze zum Platzen der Ampel
kommt auch wenn man es natürlich nicht
ausschließen kann es sind wie gesagt
sehr sehr dicke bretteter die daz Bohen
sind und äh man muss sich da auf vieles
einigen aber es gibt ein genuines
Interesse aus dem gerade genannten Grund
glaube ich ähm dass man trotzdem
zueinander hält damit ist dann auch
glaube ich die Frage von Leo beantwortet
der nämlich auch gefragt hat wann folgt
denn der Rücktritt der Ampel dann lass
uns mal über die Bretter sprechen die da
gebohrt werden müssen wo sind denn die
größten Streitpunkte vielleicht mussen
wir zunächst noch mal ein Schritt
zurücktritten und auf die Bretter
insgesamt gucken wie dick das denn
insgesamt ist weil äh du hast eben die
17 Milliarden genannt die hatte der
Bundesfinanzminister ja letzte Woche in
dem Interview bei uns bei was nun
genannt erstmals hatten wir da eine Zahl
allerdings wirurd ein wenig später
bekannt dass sich bei diesen 17
Milliarden
wohl bezieht auf Hilfen an die Ukraine
z.B Militärausgaben auch
Flüchtlingshilfe solche Kosten und dass
ist darüber hinaus noch mal 13
Milliarden Euro geben soll die sich auf
KTF Projekte bezieht KTF das ist dieser
Klima und
Transformation transformationsfond wir
erinnern uns bei um den ging es ja bei
dem
Verfassungsgerichtsurteil und
es Drang nach außen dass beim letzten
Koalitionsausschuss Finanzminister
Lindner wohl gesagt hat diese 17
Milliarden die beziehen sich wie gesagt
auf andere Dinge und dann noch mal 13
Milliarden
wo es um KTF Projekte ging das heißt 30
Milliarden das heißt ist tatsächlich
sehr sehr viel Geld um das da geht das
heißt man wird das durch Einsparung mit
der Nagelschere auch nicht hinbekommen
da bräuchte man dann wenn schon die
Kettensäge oder eben als Hintertürchen
äh möglicherweise auch wieder das wird
ja vor allem aus der SPD und auch von
den Grünen gefordert
aus den Fraktionen heraus doch wieder
auch eine Notlage für 2024 zu
beschließen das hat der Finanzminister
und die FDP insgesamt wiederum ähm
ziemlich kategorisch ausgeslossen
weitestgehend zumindest auch da war
Christian Lindner in unserer Sendung was
nun nicht mehr ganz so kategorisch
ähm aber auch da gilt natürlich das
Urteil des Verfassungsgerichts ähm dass
die dass die Latte da sehr hochgelegt
wurde und das muss man sich insofern
genau überlegen die Union hat in Person
des
ähm Vorsitzendes Haushaltsausschusses
gerade noch mal gesagt na wenn ihr 2024
wieder eine Notlage erklärt äh könnte es
durchaus sein äh dass wir das wieder
prüfen lassen vom
Bundesverfassungsgericht also ob diese
Hintertür dann am Ende gewählt wird ist
nicht ausgeschlossen aber auch das wird
man prüfen müssen dazu vielleicht noch
die diese eine Ergänzung und da drang
jetzt in den letzten Tagen sozusagen
eine eine
ähm Variante ans Licht dass man die
ukrainehilfe als besondere Notlage
beschreibt und die sozusagen aus dem
normalen Haushalt rauszieht und
ausklammert aber auch da gibt's
Verfassungsrechtler die da durchaus
Fragezeichen hinter die Zulässigkeit
eines solchen Vorgehens
setzen weil
m
andere Einsätze andere außerplanmäßige
Ausgaben in der Vergangenheit ja auch
nicht direkt eine Notlage nach sich
gezogen haben vielen Dank Daniel für den
Augenblick wir schalten nachher noch mal
zu dir weil vielleicht hat sich ja bis
dahin dann doch was ergeben im
Kanzleramt danke für die Einschätzung
für den Moment und bevor wir mit
Professor Grimm über die Details
sprechen ein kurzer Überblick über die
größten Streitthemen und Knackpunkte die
Ampel ringt um eine Lösung im
Haushaltsstreit die Bundesregierung muss
im nächsten Jahr laut Finanzminister
Lindner ein Loch von 17 Milliarden Euro
stopfen an der Schuldenbremse will er
aber festhalten ein Fehler findet der
Ökonom Jens südkum Deutschland hat ja
kein schen Problem wir haben momentan
ein Schuldenbremsen Problemem das heißt
wir können es uns eigentlich leisten und
müssen es uns leisten die Investitionen
um die es gerade geht auch wirklich zu
finanzieren gefährdet sind vor allem
grüne Wirtschaftsprojekte von den 57,6
Milliarden aus dem Klima und
transformationsfond sollte das meiste
Geld in die Gebäudesanierung fließen
aber auch in den Aufbau erneuerbare
Energien in die Elektromobilität in den
Schienenverkehr in die chipipproduktion
und in den Aufbau einer grünen
wasserstoffindustrie die USA ist viel
stärker verschuldet als Deutschland und
trotzdem wird dort im großen Stil Geld
auf den Tisch gelegt um
Zukunftstechnologien Zukunftsindustrien
anzusiedeln und Deutschland ist so
defensiv obwohl wir viel weniger
Schulden haben Deutschland steht gut da
in diesem Jahr beträgt die
Staatsverschuldung rund 66% des
Bruttoinlandsprodukts im Vergleich mit
anderen führenden Industrienationen der
G7 Staaten hat Deutschland mit Abstand
die niedrigste
Staatsverschuldung tja und darüber
spreche ich mit Frau Professor Veronika
Grimm sie ist seit April 2020 Mitglied
des Sachverständigen Rats Wirtschaft
also eine sogenannte
Wirtschaftsweise und Professorin für
volkswirtschaftslehr an der friedrich-
Alexander Universität Erlangen Nürnberg
Frau Professor Grimm ich sehe hier in
den Chats dass sich ganz viele darüber
informieren möchten wie das mit der
Schulden Bremse ist und wir haben das ja
auch gerade in den äh in den äh in dem
Beitrag gesehen ich möchte gerne im
weiteren Verlauf der Sendung mit ihnen
darüber sprechen woran man sparen kann
welche Möglichkeiten es da im Haushalt
gibt aber lassen Sie uns doch die
Schuldenbremse mal nach vorne Stellen
ähm es gibt einen User der schreibt
deutschland hat im internationalen
Vergleich wenige Schulden was würden Sie
mit der Schuldenbremse machen und
inwiefern sind sie D Kor mit dem Kollege
gen südikum den wir gerade gehört
haben ja guten Abend
m das ist eine interessante Frage
deutschland hat im internationalen
Vergleich wenig Schulden jetzt muss man
die Situation sich genau angucken ich
glaube wir sind in ein bisschen anderen
Situation als in den USA wir haben in
der Europäischen Union eine gemeinsame
Geldpolitik und wir haben verschiedene
Staaten die unterschiedlich hohe
Schuldenniveaus haben und wie gut man
sich in Krisen wie der coronakrise oder
wie auch der Energiekrise Verschulden
kann um diese Krisen abzufedern mit viel
Geld das hat Deutschland ja gemacht das
hat die EU gemacht das hängt eben davon
ab wie tragfähig die Staatsfinanzen sind
und wie viel Kreditwürdigkeit den
Staaten an den Märkten beigemessen wird
und da ist natürlich ein niedriges
Schuldenniveau eher gut weil man dann
Spielräume flexibilitäten hat für Krisen
die noch kommen können wie hoch das ganz
genau ist da kann man sich drüber
streiten aber auf jeden Fall ist es in
Italien z.B oder auch in Spanien schon
bedenklich hoch
und dass wir uns in der EU Verschulden
konnten in der coronakrise z.B gemeinsam
das lag schon daran dass andere Staaten
eben eine gute Tragfähigkeit der
Schulden hatten also ich glaube man
sollte das Thema nicht runterspielen
weil wir ja auch weltpolitisch in einer
Situation sind wo die Krisen sich
durchaus häufen werden also wir haben ja
relativ viele Konfliktherde im
Windschatten der Konflikt FDE werden
andere Konflikte weltweit angezettelt
und dass es uns in naher Zukunft noch
mal trifft ist schon da nicht
unwahrscheinlich und dann ist es
natürlich so dass immer Krisen kommen
können die man gar nicht vorhergesehen
hat wir hatten ja auch nicht erwartet
dass ein Virus die ganze Welt LM legt
und insofern ist es schon gut ein Puffer
zu haben und das garantiert natürlich
unsere Schulden Bremse in besonderem
Maße indem sie uns nicht erlaubt uns für
Zukunftsinvestitionen zu verschulden
warum ist das so kategorisch warum nimmt
man jetzt Investitionen nicht aus nun
das tut man nicht weil man ja alles
mögliche als Definitionen ähm ausweisen
kann ähm z.B wurde jetzt häufig gesagt
das S alles Investitionen in den
Klimaschutz aber worum es sich
eigentlich handelt bei vielen Projekten
das sind Subventionen für große
Unternehmen ähm z.B Hilfen um mit den
hohen Energiepreisen klar zukommen
Hilfen für Unternehmen die vielleicht
auch tatsächlich dauerhaft
Schwierigkeiten haben ein tragfähiges
Geschäftsmodell in Deutschland zu haben
ähm Subventionen für Chipfabriken das
sind jetzt auch keine Investitionen in
dem Sinne sondern Subventionen für
bestimmte Firmen die diese Chipfabriken
hier errichten da fragt sich auch ist
das jetzt zu hoch gegriffen was man da
an Geld ausgibt an Intel an TSMC dann
sind es Gelder die für Heizungstausch
äh gewährt werden z.B auch für Familien
ähm für Haushalte die sich durchaus eine
eigene Heizung selber leisten können
also da fragt sich muss man das
eigentlich machen dass man solche
Mitnahmeeffekte erzeugt ähm das sind
auch alles keine Investitionen im
eigenen Sinne dass sozusagen Kapital
aufgebaut wird das dann zukünftigen
Generationen nützt sondern das sind oft
Hilfszahlungen an äh Personen die
aktuell in die predulie geraten ja aber
man muss sich eben in der im Sinne der
generationerechtigkeit bei diesen Dingen
auch immer fragen ähm wollen wir jetzt
auf Kosten der zukünftigen Generation
also mit Schulden den Leuten heute
erleichtern Ihren Lebensstandard zu
halten oder muss man nicht wenn man sagt
man möchte eine Transformation gemeinsam
angehen und schaffen muss dann nicht
jeder auch einen Teil an dieser
Transformation Teil der Last tragen z.B
die Kosten eben eine klimafreundliche
Heizungsanlage zu installieren
diejenigen die das können eigentlich
müssten wir die
klimatransformation eben sozial viel
gerechter gestalten also denjenigen die
die nicht tragen können helfen und das
geschieht ja nicht mal also insofern ist
es nicht so klar was tut man denn wenn
mehr Geld da wäre würde man eigentlich
das Richtige tun das ist auch nicht
unbedingt gesagt ja zu dem klimaaspekt
und den möglichen Investitionen oder
Sparmaßnahmen kommen wir gleich wird
aber gern noch bei der Schuldenbremse
bleiben es gibt einen User der stimmt
ihnen insofern den Teilen zu der sagt
nur weil in anderen Ländern die
Staatsverschuldung höher liegt heißt das
nicht dass es sinnvoll ist mehr Schulden
zu machen teilweise ist die Verwendung
der Mittel kritikwürdig sagt dieser User
aber es gibt eben auch viele Stimmen die
sagen man müsste die Schuldenbremse
reformieren z.B sagt das Professor
Christian Kastrop der als Vater der
Schuldenbremse gilt weil er 2009 Beamter
im Finanzministerium war und sie mit
ausgearbeitet hat und der hat selbst im
heute journal gesagt meiner Meinung nach
kann sie nicht weg wir brauchen sie
immer noch aber es heißt schon auch dass
man nach 14 Jahren Praxis drüber
nachdenken kann sie hier und da
anzupassen und in dieselbe Kerbe schlägt
ein User namens philiip eisenfeld der
fragt wie könnte eine Reformierung der
Schuldenbremse aus
Aussehen ja man kann sicherlich darüber
nachdenken etwas daran zu machen also
z.B die Möglichkeit der verschuld
der strukturellen Verschuldung etwas
erhöhen solange man einen niedrigen
Schuldenstand
hat viele Vorschläge gehen in die
Richtung Investitionen von der
Schuldenbremse auszunehmen und das ist
nicht so ganz einfach weil wie gesagt
die Frage ist was definiert man dann als
investien da werden viele Sachen
wahrscheinlich in diesen Topf
geschmissen die eigentlich nicht
wirklich Investitionen in die Zukunft
sind also das ganze wird politisiert und
es ist eben sehr schwer zu managen das
so eine einfache Schuldenregel unter um
einfacher zu handhaben und das aktuelle
Problem hat ja nun zwei Facetten das
eine ist ist die Schuldenbremse zu
restriktiv und das andere ist man hat
sich schon verzockt man hat die Corona
Schulden und die Kreditermächtigungen
aus diesen Krisen umgewidmet und über
die Jahre verschoben und das hat eben
widersprochen den Grundsätzen die
eigentlich im Grundgesetz festgelegt
sind deswegen haben wir jetzt ein
besonders großes Problem das heißt wenn
wir jetzt sagen würden wir passen die
Schuldenbremse an um dieser Problematik
die ja zum gewissen Umfang selbsterzeugt
ist gerecht zu werden dann würde das so
sein wie hungrig einkaufen gehen dann
würde man wahrscheinlich zu viel machen
also ich glaube man sollte das separat
voneinander adressieren man muss jetzt
das Haushaltsproblem lösen und da muss
man wirklich sich zusammensetzen und
sehen wo wie schafft man es das zu lösen
und dann kann man natürlich einen
Reformprozess anstrengen aber da muss
man wirklich sehr genau hingucken dass
wir nicht in die Situation kommen wie
andere europäische Staaten da war es
nämlich jetzt in den Jahren seit der
Finanzkrise so dass in vielen
europäischen Staaten vor allen Dingen in
den großen Volkswirtschaften Italien
Spanien Frankreich die Schuldenstände in
wirtschaftlich sehr guten Zeiten immer
weiter gestiegen sind und zwar auf ein
Niveau gestiegen sind dass Italien in
der coronakrise z.B die Hilfe anderer
europäischer Staaten brauchte um diese
Hilfen überhaupt zu bekommen also da
haben wir gemeinsam europäisch
geschuldet um Italien zu helfen und das
geht auch weil wir gut da stehen nun
gibt es ausländische Kommentatoren die
in Teilen den Kopf schütteln also das
us-nachrichtenportal politico z.B
spottet über eine herbeifantasierte
Schuldenkrise und ein Kommentator im
Spiegel schreibt heute die Politik ist
damit beschäftigt einen Schuldenberg
abzutragen der schon in seiner jetzigen
Höhe kein Problem darstellt was sagen
sie dazu ja ich glaube dass natürlich
Interessen da sind dass Deutschland mehr
Geld äh ausgibt um alle möglichen
Probleme zu lösen aber ich glaube wir
sollten gerade im der Nachhaltigkeit
genau wie beim Klima ähm auch bei den
Staatsfinanzen darüber nachdenken wir
schaffen es uns so aufzustellen dass wir
langfristig für unsere zukünftigen
Generationen auch eine Stabilität
gewährleisten können und
das natürlich es auch Kommentatoren aus
anderen Staaten oder auch
Interessengruppen in Deutschland gut
passt wenn der Staat mehr Geld auf den
Tisch legt natürlich natürlich wenn der
Staat die Schatulle öffnet dann stehen
natürlich alle möglichen Akteure da und
wollen ein ein Teil venkuchen abhaben
das ist ganz normal und das haben wir
auch schon immer beobachtet aber dafür
sind ja gerade regeln da und ich glaube
die sollte man sich wenn man sie
reformiert sollte man sich das genau
angucken und sollte auf jeden Fall eine
Reform initiieren die eben nicht dazu
führt dass die Schulden stetig nach oben
gehen sondern dass man einfach weiß dass
man in 5 10 Jahren immer noch tragfähige
Staatsfinanzen hat und das braucht Ruhe
das würde man sicherlich nicht in so
einer Krisensitzung wie heute abend
machen
dann schauen wir mal auf die junge
Generation und auf das Thema Klima wir
haben dazu einen oton von einem
Aktivisten von Fridays for future namens
jo und der sagt wenn man im klimasektor
jetzt spart dann hat man zwar die
nächste Generation vor mehr Schulden
bewahrt hat aber trotzdem an der
falschen Stelle gespart hören wir mal
rein Christian Lindner vor allem als
Finanzminister muss verstehen er spricht
von sparen und er möchte eigentlich
gerne dass wir der nächsten Generation
keine Schulden hinterlassen das Problem
ist aber er übersieht dabei keine
finanziellen Schulden bedeutet wir haben
Schulden in nicht getätigten
Investitionen ja also bei Fridays for
future ist der Tenor ihr müsst jetzt
investieren im Sinne der nächsten
Generation und dazu müsst ihr jetzt Geld
ausgeben ja aber ich glaube es wird
verkannt dass es nicht darum geht jetzt
staatliches Geld auszugeben und zwar
sondern es geht darum möglichst viel zu
investieren um die Wirtschaft zu
transformieren wenn man sich die
gesamtwirtschaftlichen Invest anguckt
sind ungefähr 90% ein bisschen weniger
als privatwirtschaftliche Investitionen
und 10% sind staatliche jetzt kann man
die staatlichen ein bisschen erhöhen
aber es kommt darauf an die
privatwirtschaftlichen Investitionen zu
mobilisieren und es kommt darauf an dass
tatsächlich alle Anreiz in die Richtung
gehen für die Akteure für die Haushalte
für die Unternehmen wirklich Klimaschutz
zu betreiben also fossile
Geschäftsmodelle zu beenden und
klimafreundliche Geschäftsmodelle zu
starten wie funktioniert es am besten
manchmal nicht mit viel staatlichen
Geldern weil z.B was wir jetzt sehen ist
dass die energieintensive Industrie sehr
stark danach fragt den aktuellen
Strompreis für Sie abzusenken um ihre
Produktion in Deutschland zu halten
dahinter steht die Idee dass man
vielleicht transformieren kann aber
darum geht es jetzt ja erstmal noch
nicht sondern eben um Hilfszahlungen für
Unternehmen die unter Umständen gar kein
Geschäftsmodell mehr haben bei uns wie
es besser ginge wäre mit einem emissions
Handel wenn wir also den Emissionshandel
und damit den die Kosten von CO2
Emissionen stärken würden erhöhen würden
dann wäre es eben wirtschaftlich sehr
ungünstig sowohl für Haushalte als auch
für
Unternehmen CO2 zu emittieren und dann
würde man auch Einnahmen generieren man
würde Einnahmen generieren und die
könnte man gleich nutzen um die
Belastung durch die hohen CO2 Preise für
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger abzufedern
wenn man das Geld zurückgibt ist es
keine Steuer in dem im Sinne dass man
die Leute schröpft sondern es ist ein
Lenkungsinstrument das dazu führt dass
die Leute das Richtige tun und man hat
Geld um es abzufiedern od dann kann man
staatliches Geld nehmen um
dann diese transformationsbemühung zu
unterstützen um
Infrastrukturen zu fördern um
Infrastrukturen zu errichten damit man
die klimaneutrale Mobilität schneller
realisieren kann und so weiter und so
fort das wäre dann eine gute Kombination
aus die Kräfte des Marktes nutzen und
auch staatlich investieren aber so wie
wir es aktuell machen dass wir versuchen
möglichst viel staatliches Geld
auszugeben um Herten abzufedern das ist
nicht besonders zielgerichtet fürt zu
vielen Mitnahmeeffekten und teilweise
auch nicht wirklich dazu dass wir
Klimaschutz betreiben mm sie haben die
Elektromobilität angesprochen Hildegard
Müller vom VDA also vom Verband der
Automobilindustrie hat dazu auch eine
Meinung hören wir uns an wir brauchen
jetzt Priorisierungen im Haushalt das
ist uns allen klar und da ist wichtig
sich auf das Wesentliche für die
Verbraucherin und Verbraucher zu
konzentrieren hier ist es ganz
entscheidend das Vertrauen in die
Ladeinfrastruktur hergestellt werden
muss tja Frau Professor Grimm auch die
Ladeinfrastruktur braucht mehr Geld das
da sind wir jetzt mittendrin bei der
Frage der Priorisierung wenn ich hier in
die Chats gucke dann sagen viele nachdem
sie heute die Meldung von Pisa gehört
haben und dass Deutschland da so
schlecht dar steht wir bräuchten
eigentlich Geld für mehr Bildung
wie wie soll diese Priorisierung denn da
gelingen wenn eigentlich alle sagen wir
brauchen mehr Geld ja genau das ist eben
das Ziel dass man mit Schulden Regeln
verfolgt wir müssen uns wenn wir
beliebig viel Geld haben dann gibt es
auch beliebig viele ausgabewünschen und
es ist natürlich so dass wir
priorisieren müssen dass wir überlegen
müssen was ist uns als Gesellschaft
besonders viel Wert und das hängt
natürlich oft mit dem Wählerwillen und
oft auch mit besonders einflussreichen
Gruppen und Lobbys zusammen Bildung hat
traditionell nicht so eine gute Lobby
also wir vernach nachlässendes
Bildungssystem oft das liegt daran dass
es ja unterschiedliche Auffassungen gibt
wie ein gutes Bildungssystem aussieht
das liegt auch daran dass diejenigen die
eigentlich bedacht werden müssen von
einem und die von einem guten
Bildungssystem profitieren sollten das
sind nämlich die sozialbenachteiligten
und die melden sich oft nicht sehr laut
um besonders gute
Bildungsinstitutionen zu bekommen und
das ist natürlich ein Problem
gleichzeitig ist es so dass unsere
Gesellschaft massiv profitieren würde
wenn wir mehr Wert legen auf gute
Bildung weil dann haben wir eben die
Arbeitskräfte der Zukunft und in
Deutschland werden qualifizierte
Fachkräfte eins einer der
Standortvorteile sein in Zukunft
Energiepreise werden es definitiv nicht
sein viele andere Aspekte auch nicht
auch wir haben auch eine sehr
umfangreiche Bürokratie also ein
schlanker stat ist auch nicht der
Standortvorteil sondern wir werden eben
die guten ausgebildet Fachkräfte haben
und m Technologie Ökosysteme äh die die
dann gut funktionieren um innovative
Unternehmen damit man innovative
Unternehmen ansiedeln kann und da müssen
wir viel investieren und das muss die
Diskussion tatsächlich hergeben wir
müssen überlegen wo es es besonders
wichtig für Deutschland Geld auszugeben
staatliches Geld auszugeben um voran
zuuk kommen und worauf können wir auch
verzichten und diese Situation haben wir
jetzt auch es muss priorisiert werden
nur in einer sehr herausfordernden
Situation weil man jetzt auf einmal
plötzlich so viel Geld nicht mehr
ausgeben kann von dem man glaubt es
Stände zur Verfügung das ist natürlich
eine besondere Herausforderung jetzt
gerade dazu ein kommmentar von einem
User mit dem schönen Namen wuffgang über
Youtube ich finde der stat hat kein
gutes Bildungssystem keine guten Straßen
und Bahnnetz das wäre zu priorisieren
schreibt dieser User und ich möchte
gerne zu einem nächsten Gebiet kommen
auf dem Christian Lindner gesagt hat an
dieser Stelle können wir sparen nämlich
beim Thema soziales und beim Thema
Bürgergeld und hier gibt es eine Mail
von Dieter Reuter der schreibt ich wäre
dafür die Erhöhung des Bürgergeldes auf
Mitte 2024 zu schieben sie haben
einflussreiche Lobbygruppen gerade
angesprochen warum ist die politische
Diskussion so sehr mit dem Fokus auf dem
Bürgergeld und nicht z.B bei den
Rentnerinnen und Rentnern bei denen sich
sicherlich auch einiges einsparen
ließe ja ich glaube zunächst mal muss
man sehen dass wenn jetzt gespart werden
muss wenn man jetzt schaffen muss diese
17 Milliarden nehmen wir mal an es sind
17 Milliarden einzusparen dann muss
natürlich man sich das Aufteilen
zwischen den Koalitionspartnern eine
wahrscheinliche Lösung ist dass einfach
die SPD beim sozialen sagen muss wo
gespart werden kann die Grünen bei den
Klimaschutzprojekten und die FDP z.B bei
Steuervergünstigungen und da kann man
natürlich beim sozialen überlegen
beim Bürgergeld im Transfersystem anzus
setzen man kann natürlich auch überlegen
es gibt schon lange immer wieder
Aufforderungen und auch sehr berechtigte
Aufforderungen das Rentensystem zu
reformieren weil es einfach nicht
tragfähig ist also die Belastung durch
die m gesetzliche Rente die wird sehr
sehr stark ansteigen weil ja jetzt die
ganzen geburtenensstarken Jahrgänge in
den Ruhestand gehen und das wird extrem
teuer werden und da werden auch die
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer und
der Bundeshaushalt extrem belastet sein
insofern wäre es schon sehr sinnvoll
dort auch anzusetzen aber wenn man
solche Vorschläge macht
was ich auch getan habe in den
vergangenen zwei Wochen
dann merkt man warum das besonders
heikel ist für die Politik weil man
bekommt dann unglaublich viel sehr
negative Fanpost
und das ist natürlich ein großer Druck
der da aufgebaut wird das geht da schon
ans Eingemachte trotzdem muss ich glaube
ich die Politik durchringen gerade beim
Rentensystem
Anpassung vorzunehmen dass die Kosten
nicht explodieren und dass auch die
Zahlungen oder die Beitragszahlungen
einfach für die arbeitenden im Rahmen
bleiben und insofern würde ich jetzt
fast sagen dass ähm man wirklich auch
mit Blick auf eine langfristige
Perspektive es ist ja nicht nur
2024 das Problem sondern es geht dann
weiter 2025 wird auch für den Haushalt
sehr herausfordernd da werden ja auch
noch Summen fehlen die man eigentlich
ursprünglich mal einplanen wollte und ab
27 26 27 28 da fängt es dann an dass die
Kredite getilt werden müssen mit denen
man die coronapandemie abgefedert hat
das heißt da sinken dann auch noch mal
die Spielräume die Politik muss sich
eigentlich jetzt schon dringend
vorausschauend überlegen was machen wir
für 25 wie schaffen wir es dass da Luft
ähm ist im Haushalt
25 ist das Wahljahr ich glaube da haben
alle Parteien der demokratischen Mitte
auch eigentlich einen großes Interesse
müssten eigentlich ein groß großes
Interesse haben für das warah wirklich
ein Lösung zu finden dass da die
Unzufriedenheit der Wählerin und Wähler
nicht massiv zunimmt aufgrund von auch
viel politischem Streit vielleicht und
für 26 27 28 ist es wichtig dass wir da
in der haushalterischen Lage sind dass
wir diese tgungsverpflichtungen auch
tatsächlich stemmen können also die
Herausforderungen gehen schon über 2024
hinaus und wenn man jetzt sparen möchte
sollte man schon an Stellen ansetzen die
dann auch nachhaltig
Beiträge zur Lösung des Problems leisten
Frau Professor Grimm drei Fragen würde
ich gerne noch an Sie stellen zwei fasse
ich mal zusammen ein User fragt ist es
volkswirtschaftlich klug in einer
Rezession zu sparen oder zu investieren
und die andere Frage von zalvan bayati
ist was ist wenn der Staat sich auf
seine Prinzipien konzentriert und die
Gestaltung dem Markt überlässt so kann
man dann auch Steuern senken und die
Wettbewerb
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit
steigern ja der User hat schon ein Punkt
also wir müssen schon schauen dass wir
die diese Gradwanderung schaffen
zwischen in der Krise unterstützen
und gleichzeitig aber eben die Kräfte
des Marktes entfachen dass wir wieder
Wachstum kriegen wir haben im
Sachverständigen Rat gerade in unserem
Gutachten eine wachstumsprojektion also
eine Projektion des Wachstumspotenzials
für dieses Jahrzehnt gemacht und da
sieht man dass das deutsche
Wachstumspotenzial sehr sehr niedrig ist
0,4% das ist ein Drittel von dem was wir
in den 2010er Jahren haben und das heißt
dass wir natürlich bei diesem
Wachstumspotenzial dann auch nicht so
ein Wachstum der Steuereinnahmen haben
und nicht mehr so viel zu verteilen
haben und da müssen wir uns mit
politischen Entscheidungen müssen wir
dagegen angehen und müssen das Wachstum
mobilisieren sass wir da wieder mehr
Luft haben ähm das ist schon eine
wichtige Komponente gleichzeitig muss
man natürlich in diesen Krisenzeiten
auch schauen dass die Leute eine gewisse
Sicherheit haben ich glaube diese
Kommunikation rund um diese Krise ist
auch deshalb besonders schädlich weil
sie die Menschen verunsichert man sollte
aber die Leute nicht verunsichern weil
Wachstum wird ja auch aktuell vom Konsum
getragen also die Leute haben wieder
mehr Realeinkommen weil ja die
Lohnverhandlungen wieder anziehen es
werden wieder aufwüchseel generiert in
den Tarifverhandlungen und die Leute
geben das Geld eigentlich auch aus und
dadurch
nimmt das Wachstum wieder so ein
bisschen fah auf wenn man sie jetzt
verunsichert dann behalten die Leute ihr
Geld ein aus Vorsicht und dann ist eben
das Wachstum nicht so dynamisch und dann
machen wir uns haben wir ein
selbstgemachtes Problem quasi ähm
insofern
da muss man wirklich drauf achten und
ich glaube das eine Gradwanderung ich
glaube man darf jetzt nicht übertreiben
sozusagen mit viel Geld auf den Tisch
liegen weil wir sind ja auch noch in dem
inflationären Umfeld z.B und muss eben
eine gute Mischung finden aus jetzt
diese Sparbemühungen hinbekommen und
gleichzeitig Wachstum mobilisieren und
mit Blick auf das war jaah also ich
könnte mir schon vorstellen wenn die
Koalition ist jetzt erstmal ein Problem
der Ampel natürlich jetzt ist natürlich
die Opposition nicht verantwortlich das
Problem für die Ampel zu lösen aber wenn
man jetzt schaut ut dass man
konsolidiert könnte ich mir schon
vorstellen dass mit Blick auf das
Wahljahr 2025 man schon überlegt wie
schafft man vielleicht durch ein
gemeinsam im Grundgesetz verankertes
Sondervermögen also mit zwei Drittel
Mehrheit wie schafft man es da
tatsächlich noch Geld zu mobilisieren
dass man dann für
transformationsaufgaben vorsieht und
wenn man das mit zwei Drittel Mehrheit
macht wie bei dem Sondervermögen
Bundeswehr dann könnte es eben dann wäre
es rechtssicher dann wäre man nicht
dieser Unsicherheit ausgesetzt das ist
wieder beklagt werden könnte ähm und man
könnte natürlich dann gemeinsam
überlegen mit einer großen politischen
Mehrheit was ist uns dann in Deutschland
besonders wichtig was sollten wir
angehen und dann sagen dafür ähm
verankern wir jetzt eine gewisse Summe
im Grundgesetz dass diese Transformation
auch vorangeht und dann könnte man sich
auch einigen was sind denn diese
Investitionen ne wo ist es besonders
wichtig ähm da gemeinsam tätig zu werden
ich glaube es würde auch das Vertrauen
der Wähler Stärken weil ähm die extremen
Parteien nehmen zu und die Gefahr ist
natürlich nicht null dass wir nach der
nächsten Bundestagswahl gar nicht mehr
eine zweirittelmhrheit der
demokratischen Parteien der Mitte im
Bundestag haben und das wäre natürlich
eine sehr sehr negative Entwicklung und
dazu bräuchte es jetzt eine
parteiübergreifende große Lösung Frau
Professor Grimm eine letzte Frage an Sie
die
ähm Schattenhaushalte Sondervermögen die
hat ja nicht die Ampel erfunden sondern
wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe war
es Theo Weigel der das damals gemacht
hat um die deutsche Einheit zu
finanzieren wenn sie sich die Debatte
heute angucken ist sie zu aufgeregt oder
ist sie angemessen
ähm dem der Größe des Themas
entsprechend ja natürlich ist die
Debatte sehr aufgeregt ähm wir haben
auch viele Herausforderungen vor der
Brust ich weine was man auch in der
ganzen Diskussion merkt ist dass wir
auch eine verunsicherheit Verunsicherung
haben weil wir uns steht ja wir sind s
ja mitten in einer Zeitenwende und zwar
nicht nur mit Blick auf die
klimatransformation sondern vor allen
Dingen auch weltpolitisch gibt es immer
mehr Krisen Herde es gibt eine
Veränderung der globalen Ordnung
ähm und das Thema Sicherheit rückt
wieder mehr in den Fokus und das ist
natürlich klar dass die Leute
unterschiedliche
Ideen haben wie man darauf reagieren
kann auch Verunsicherung spüren und es
dann schnell polarisiert wird ich glaube
wichtig ist jetzt dass wir schaffen dass
wir in diesen sehr bewegten Zeiten
wichtige Institutionen die uns helfen
ähm diese Transformation auch wirklich
langfristig umzusetzen dass wir diese
Institutionen jetzt nicht zur
Disposition stellen und ähm aus
gewissermaßen Panik sagen jetzt brauchen
wir viel Geld jetzt schaffen wir die
staatlichen Schuldenregeln ab jetzt oder
am Energiemarkt sagen jetzt gehen die
Preise am Energiemarkt hoch jetzt
schaffen wir die Energiemärkte ab oder
Deckeln die oder regulieren die weil das
sind schon alles Institutionen die Wicht
sind um in diesem komplexen Gebild in
dem wir uns befinden alle Akteure zu
koordinieren die Politik dass sie nicht
um die wler an sich zu binden unsinnige
Ausgaben macht in sehr sehr großem
Umfang Märkte sind gut um z.B die
Energiemärkte haben sehr geholfen die
Akteure zu koordinieren dabei wo dann
Energie gespart werden konnte in der
Energiekrise die preise sind zwar hoch
gegangen aber es hat auch eine
Lenkungsfunktion
indem es den Konsum reduziert hat ähm
und dadurch natürlich auch das
knappheitsproblem wirklich auf eine gute
Weise gelöst hat und ich glaube da
müssen wir sehr aufpassen dass wir in
dieser hitzigen Situation nicht ähm
vorschnell Institutionen in Frage
stellen die eigentlich sehr sehr wichtig
sind um in die Zukunft
ähm zu gehen und vor allen Dingen die
großen Probleme unseres Landes vor allen
Dingen klimatransformation
Digitalisierung Herstellung von
Sicherheit Diversifizierung von ähm
Handelsbeziehung so dass wir nicht mehr
so abhängig sind das müssen wir lösen
aber eben in
einem sicheren äh regulatorischen Umfeld
auf das man sich auch verlassen kann und
vor allen Dingen nicht nur morgen
sondern eben auch noch in 15 Jahren Frau
Professor Grimm wenn ich hier in die
Chats gucke dann sehe ich eine lebhafte
Diskussion das ist natürlich super wenn
die Userinnen und User untereinander
auch viele Argumente austauschen ich
sehe hier beamtenrente sollte
abgeschafft werden freies Bankenwesen
sollte eingeführt werden das würde einen
Währung Wettbewerb schaffen
dann geht es auch viel um die
Reichensteuer um Vermögenssteuer
Erbschaftssteuer Digitalisierung also
diese ganzen Themen sind hier im Chat
und ich möchte sie gerne verabschieden
mit einer Frage von Alex der fragt
nämlich kann Veronika Grimm nicht zur
Bundestagswahl antreten das wäre doch
ein
kompetenzgewinn vielen Dank Frau
Professor Grimm dass sie mit dem Stream
waren und gerne bis zum nächsten Mal ich
danke Ihnen und dann gehen wir noch mal
nach Berlin zu Daniel ponzen ins
Hauptstadtstudio und stellen die Frage
any news aus dem Kanzleramt Daniel no
news so far und wie gesagt es wä auch
angesichts der vielen Aspekte die auch
Frau Professor Grimm gerade angesprochen
hat aus meiner Sicht eher überraschend
sollte da noch was kommen zumal sie auch
den Aspekt angesprochen hat dass man den
Haushalt 25 ja zumindest mitdenken muss
das war auch die Forderung
von Finanzminister Lindner gleich nach
dem Urteil aus Karlsruhe dass man da
insofern nichts überstürzen solle und um
da nur ein Stichwort zu nennen die
Kindergrundsicherung die D sozusagen
scharf gestellt wird die kommt jetzt
auch noch mal in diese ganze
Verhandlungsmasse mit rein zumindest
nach nach Willen der FDP und dadurch
dass ja im Grunde alle Themen da jetzt
noch mal reinkommen wird sicher auch
darum gehen und wenn man äh zurückdenkt
wie harsch dazu gerungen wurde im Sommer
schon ähm und jetzt äh in Rechnung
stellt dass das nur ein einziger von
vielen Aspekten ist glaube ich braucht
man in der Tat Fantasie dafür dass ä
dass dann die große Einigung innerhalb
der nächsten Stunden kommt es sei denn
man hat in den letzten Tagen schon so
viel vorarbeitet Vorarbeit geleistet in
den Kulissen ähm dass man das jetzt
finalisiert aber ich glaube die
wartungshaltung sollte da nicht allzu
groß
sein an Mac hatte gefragt wie du das
einstätetzt ob es eine Einigung möglich
ob eine Einigung möglich ist nachdem die
FDP weder die Schuldenbremse aussetzen
will noch Steuern erhöhen möchte darüber
hast du gerade
gesprochen Daniel letzte Frage an dich
Frau Professor grim hat angesprochen man
könnte im Grundgesetz verankern für
welche Bereiche man wie viel Geld
ausgeben will und sie hat auch die
politische Dimension klar gemacht mit
Blick auf die nächste Bundestagswahl
2025 und den Herausforderungen die diese
Demokratie hat glaubst du man
entscheidet sich in der Ampel jetzt eher
für einen kleinen Wurf also man sagt wir
sparen da wir sparen da wir sparen da
oder man versucht tatsächlich ein
parteiübergreifendes großes
Konzept zu erarbeiten um das im
Grundgesetz so zu verankern wie Frau
Grimm das gerade gesagt
hat ich glaube dass man das trennen muss
also dass tatsächlich die Ampel jetzt
erstmal ihr Problem äh selbst lösen muss
äh dass
äh die Hausaufgaben die jetzt sozusagen
Karlsruhe auferlegt hat dass dass die
Ampel da jetzt sich sozusagen selbst aus
aus dieser Sackgasse manövrieren muss ä
in die sich da gebracht hat
ähm darüber hinaus ist in der Tat
durchaus denkbar dass es zu
einem wie auch immer genannten neuen
Sondervermögen kommen könnte ähm mit mit
Zustimmung der Union die DAF notwendig
wäre wenn es Umrissen wäre
Transformation
in der der Wirtschaft und Industrie in
eine klimafreundliche Zukunft aber da
hat CDU Chef merärz ja schon gesagt dass
man da dann sehr sehr genau hingucken
will
wie das dann definiert ist
die Union fühlt sich da so ein bisschen
ähm
nicht ganz ernst genommen bei dem
letzten Sondervermögen
Bundeswehr weil da jetzt eben nicht nur
Anschaffung für die bundesw mit
finanziert werden sondern auch laufende
Kosten sozusagen also da würde die Union
dann sicher den Preis hochtreiben und
eigene
[Musik]
eigene Prestigeprojekte da
möglicherweise dann reinverhandeln aber
ich würde sagen das ist tatsächlich eher
eine mittelbare Geschichte jetzt erstmal
geht's darum dass die Ampel das akute
Problem selbst löst sagt unser
hauptstadtkorrespondent Daniel ponzen
vielen Dank nach Berlin
gerne tja liebe Userinnen und User wir
gehen davon aus dass es in dieser Nacht
keine Lösungen gibt aber wir lassen uns
natürlich überraschen immer informiert
seid ihr mit ZDF heute und wir danken
fürs eifrige muntere und informierte
mitdiskutieren und Fragen in den Chats
bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss
ه